[موسيقى]
ارسل لي موقعك عباره قد تسمعها يوميا عده
مرات وقد تستخدمها مرارا تغنيك عن التوهان
برحله قياده داخل مدينه او ريف وتشير
بالضروره الى استخدام اشارات راديويه ضمن
نظام عرف بي الجي بي اس فما قصته
في الرابع من اكتوبر عام
1957 لاحظ العلماء في معهد ماسيتشوست
ان تردد الاشارات الرديويه التي يرسلها
القمر الصناعي الروسي الصغير قد ازداد مع
اقترابه وانخفض مع تحركه بعيدا كان السبب
في ذلك هو تاثير ظاهره دوبلر وهو نفس
الشيء الذي يجعل جرس بوق السياره يتغير
معا دفاع السياره اعطى هذا العلماء فكره
عظيمه بانه من الممكن تتبع الاقمار
الصناعيه من الارض عن طريق قياس تردد
اشاره الراديو التي ترسلها وعلى العكس من
ذلك يمكن تتبع مواقع اجهزه الاستقبال على
الارض من خلال المسافه التي تفصلها عن
الاقمار الصناعيه في عام
استخدمت وكاله مشروعات الابحاث المتقدمه
اي ار بي اي هذا لتطوير اول نظام ملاحه
عالمي عبر الاقمار الصناعيه في العالم
الذي سمي ترانزيت وقامت الوكاله باطلاق
اول قمر صناعي له في عام
1960 بغرض توفير الملاحه للمستخدمين
العسكريين
والتجاريين
استخدم النظام حينها لتحديد موقع الغواصات
وبدا بسته اقمار صناعيه ونمائله عشره قبل
ان ينقل الى البحريه الامريكيه في منتصف
الستينيات
بحلول عام
1968 كانت كوكبه من 36 قمرا صناعيا مرتبطه
بالنظام تعمل بكامل طاقتها في عام
1974 اطلق الجيش الامريكي قمر نايف ستار
وهو اول قمر صناعي مقترح لنظام الجي بي اس
واجري عليه اكثر من 700 اختبار
بين عامي
و979 لتاكيد دقه النظام المستخدم استعدادا
لبدء استخدام نظام جي بي اس بلوك وان في
اوائل الثمانينيات
شهدت هذه الفتره ظهور اسم نسوي بين اصحاب
الانجاز هي عالمه الرياضيات الامريكيه
السيده غلاد سويست التي قامت بعمل ما عرف
بنمذجه شكل الارض رياضيا وطورت نماذج
الجيوديسي الفضائيه المستخدمه في انظمه
تحديد المواقع العالميه الجي بي اس ونسب
لها دور كبير في تحسين النظام ورغم
المخاوف من فتح المجال امام توسيع قاعده
المستخدمين الا ان الرئيس الامريكي رونالد
ريجن اذن عام
1983 باستخدام النظام من قبل شركات
الطيران التجاريه المدنيه في محاوله
لتحسين الملاحه وسلامه للسفر الجوي كما تم
اطلاق اول قمر صناعي يعمل بنظام جي بي اس
بلوك 2 على صاروخ دلتا 2 مع التطور
المستمر بنظام تحديد المواقع العالمي جي
بي اس امتدت استخداماته الى حياه الافراد
العاديين فظهرت تقنيه جي بي اس لاول مره
في هاتف محمول في عام
1999 عندما اصدرت
ثم بدات تقنيه جي بي اس تعمل في السيارات
في عام 2005 تم اطلاق اول جيل جديد من
الاقمار الصناعيه لنظام تحديد المواقع
العالمي المسمى بلوك 2 فيما تم تفعيل
الجيل التالي من الاقمار الصناعيه لنظام
الجي بي اس المسمى بلوك 3 في عام 2014
في عام 2018 تم اطلاق اول قمر صناعي لنظام
جي بي اس 3 تلاهو الثاني في عام 2019 ثم
اطلق القمران الصناعيان الثالث والرابع
على صواريخ فالكون 9 في عام 2020 فيما
ينتظر اطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه السته
المتبقيه خلال عام 2023 الحالي التقنيه
التي عرفها العالم عن طريق الصدفه شهدت
مخاوف كبيره من فتح مجالات استخدامها بشكل
واسع ومع ذلك فان ضرورات مختلفه جعلتها
مباحه امام الاستخدام الشعبي وباتت جزءا
من تطبيقات كثيره لا يمكن الاستغناء عنها
في روتين الحياه اليومي